des cabines de d'aurier des ballons vous
allez prendre une fourchette chacun une
fourchette alors on prend la forge et on
peut crever des ballons et ce qu'on veut
sa tête ses talons ses pieds ses
oreilles gilles verdez ans il va tous
mourir peuvent tous les pays ah oui et
le plus vite possible celui qui a tout
pété tout péter des ballons bien sûr se
qualifier pour le round après au clair
il ya le même nombre de ballons on est
évidemment ça a été concoctée par une
autre chognard vous inquiétez pas super
six il ya 40 à l'étroit dans des cabines
tu prends à quel bon faux sang contre
tension toujours des questions
oui j'oubliais aux malades
et n'ont même pas en vue comptable
allez tout
alors nicolas franchement banham
attendait si vous vous placez dames 1
bravo c'est bien c'est bien alors vous
n'avez pas été très bon c'est comme ça
qu'ils nous disent c'est comme ça bravo
nicolas pernikoff je me suis dit ça va
écouter regarder ça désinfectant s'avère
devient super voilà ça au piquet merci
beaucoup
donc me connais pas les clubs se
qualifient pour le blanc deux suivants
voilà j'ai un peu mal vécu cet illuminé
par merci beaucoup entrer dans la cabine
prenez une fourchette
celui qui claquent tous les ballons le
plus vite possible se qualifie d' accor
en premier en fait d'accord c'est clair
alors rentrer dans les cabines attendait
mon top
allez allez tu veux les routes
c'est la rentrée dedans voilà ça
commence bien prenez la prochaine à
attendez attendez attendez attendez le
coup ils ne comprennent rien c'est un
drame et attendait 3 fraîche 2 à top
les hausses avance
monte et l'on sent qu'il est
d'expérience à
mais oui
voilà
là
abra voilée
c'est bon débit n'est défini voilà bravo
bernard
alors vous avez fait ça en 19 secondes
et j'ai vu le petit coup de cul pour
claquer un ballon très très fort
incroyable mais il sait le meilleur
temps ça fait de voir un favori
d'ailleurs pour commencer à choisir
votre favori alors je rappelle le
meilleur baba est en finale et qui va
affronter le meilleur des chroniqueurs
ça pour l'instant je arrêter au principe
est simple dans ceux qui aiment une
téléphonie qui sont juste là il ya des
ballons non je confie une fourchette
très mira chacun écrit comme avant top
et uniquement à mon top parce que le
fait pas comme les autres qui n'écoutent
rien vous ne connaissez pas son école
tf1 crs épreuve les nerfs des éclairs
voilà vous l'école ne sais pas quoi mais
c'est vrai qu'on situe donc à mon top
vous éclater le plus de ballons le plus
vite possible c'est lui qui a fini en
premier ce qu'elle ici rien faire cet
accord ne marche pas avec ce que vous
voulez donnez moi juste une question on
se qualifie pour gagner quoi alors que
vous connaissez la meinau rien espagne
et je dois les aimer démons place ben
oui voilà ne fait pas tomber les ballons
2 à la rentrée bit n'a pas non plus 7
heures à temps des atomes et non mais né
voilà alors à mon top et uniquement à
mon top peu près 3 2 1 go
david gill
non
jeu ouais je le sens bien belles rimes
et franchement il va y aller franchement
je pensais pas vous soyez si bolt était
à mes terres peut l'assister assisté
bien dans les coins les amis en russie
palayer alors on va quand même moment
quand même mettre comme la victoire de
gilles suis désolé soit des 10 donc mois
soit guillaume genton c'est donc
l'affrontement la fonction que vous et
moi ouais on va rentrer ensemble dans la
cabine
ouais à mon top et seulement à mon top
ouais vous commencerez à je ne sais pas
si je rentre dans un communiqué mais si
vous rentrez vient ce goût rentrée on
commence à éclater des ballons vous êtes
prêts à attendre alors on va monter mon
top pour l'instant on ne fait rien voilà
à mon top on ne suis rien on ne commence
pas c'est vrai oui c'est bon 3 2 go
et
[Musique]
dégoûté allez-vous le reste encore sa
forme d'une fois moins de dextérité
merci je suis bien content et je vais
donc me qualifiez moi même parce qu'il
me fait bien plaisir voilà c'est bien
pourtant les amis vous êtes prêts pour
cette demi scénario oui mais moi je veux
aller là bas valais ou les mails et les
évitera les évitera les attendait mon
tour et attends toi à qui on démonte on
triche allait rentrer rentrent doucement
voilà du sport pour de ce format vous
commencez avant lui à les et à l'isi
allez-y pas maintenant pas maintenant
pas mal quand nicolas n'ont pas encore
entendu nicolas
voilà
les abords leurs querelles et jaune
n'est pas comprise comme ça je suppose
je vous rappelle que furent les jours
j'aime
lalala lalala lalala
la prétention du dia quand il dort
non mais
c'est bon c'est fini voilà ma belle
l'année comme il a éclaté 40 ballons ce
qui est pas non plus les policiers
il sort genre en quelques heures n'a
manqué que l'on arrêté voilà arrétez
arrétez arrétez allons tutrice père du
coureur
tu triches ouais elle avait la sortie
les sorties que mais demain à l'apollo
way
vous n allez avoir du bon
amis en attendant l'autre demi finale
qui va donc m'opposer à vers des soldats
que normalement la baisse je vais je
vais m'éclater
je vais m'éclater lennon verdez parce
que c'est pour énerver un petit soit il
est bon il est bon chez lui mais ici il
n'est nul vous inquiétez pas les nus il
vous est prêt pour cette demi finale
oui alors vous devez prendre votre
fourchette d'accord vous allez rappelle
que pour l'instant qualifiés en finale
c'est c'est notre ami ni grebennikov
alors j'espère l'affronter donc j'ai
tout faire pour vous d'accord pour vous
battre mais on essayait en moins de 10
secondes
wang yadong vous attendez vous attendez
qu'on soit tous les deux dans temps
j'aimerais doucement doucement vous
rentrez doucement a déjà ils n'arrivent
pas à rentrer tous rentrer doucement
pavés et uniquement à mon top on y va
avait tué près d'autres pas
[Musique]
là j'ai mille qu'il a gagné et voilà je
vais donc avoir le plaisir et l'honneur
d'affronter nicolas pernikoff pour la
petite finale
juste avant d'affronter évidemment baba
pour la grande finale ça va montrer
l'autre munch évidemment je suis content
de vous voir si c'est la finale c'est
bon ça c'est la petite finale c'est
toujours vole sa main contre monique au
bon on y va et bravo je viens ici tous
le même nombre de ballons week-end alors
serré le 40 ballons on a le droit de le
faire avec une fourchette ou autre chose
mais dans votre cas la défaite sera
suffisant ps merci vous est prêt 3 2 1
go
[Musique]
j'étais encore les
très fort nous colle à savoir c'est fini
c'est incroyable non toi tu vois c'est
très très fort je pense que nicolas est
le champion qu'est ce qui se passe avec
c'est encore notre émission dont il faut
animer un peu mais c'est ma vie ma
finale jeunes perdent pas et ils font
pas souvent me bassinez pas tout le
temps non mais moi comment tu veux que
son poids sa retraite rené dont elle
expliqué je déjeunais je vous accompagne
on sait pas faire votre chef là mécha
supportable non ils vont rentrer dans
ses cahiers de gaulle faisait que vous
connaissez par coeur il ya 40 ballons le
premier qui a pété tous les ballons
remporté la grande finale
uniquement à mon top série ne trichait
pas comme d'habitude chez pathé alors si
je ne compterais mal alors vous triez
tout le temps là je vous dis je me
prenez le comme vous voulez vous devez
de l'état tricheurs à les y aller et à
tous attendez mon top série
oui on sera attention 3 2 qui va égorger
un poulet cyril à 3 2
tu vas pas partout
[Musique]
ça veut dire merci à toutes les pme
croyable tout le monde aime ça
incroyable mais j'ai perdu et s'est
éclatée comme ça comment
a la roma et vous allez perdre ou se
désole c'est que les patrons sa victoire
ce n'est pas la perdre et qui sera donc
devant tina krach lundi à d'accord alors
vous auriez center c'est lui ne voit pas
quand exactement à très bas a très très
bien joué
ah ouais ça veut dire que vous avez vu
arriver avant dans l'émission il devient
quoi voyez plutôt
c'est pas sûr c'est quoi ça